foreign ministers met at nato and then
at the eu to discuss what more they can
do to help ukraine as their fears grow
that the russian campaign will intensify
we are now witnessing a full fledged war
in our borders
a war unleashed by president putin
against ukraine
and
a completely unjustified war
that's creating a lot of civilian
casualties
with the use of arms strictly prohibited
by the
geneva convention
nato and eu countries have already
agreed to supply weapons to ukraine and
to put in place some of the toughest
sanctions in history
but the ukrainian foreign minister who
dressed them by video wants much more
direct support including the imposition
of a no-fly zone
we are ready to fight we will continue
fighting
but help us
if you don't
i'm afraid you will have to share
responsibility for the lives and
sufferings of civilian ukrainians this
was the response from nato's secretary
general our assessment is that we
understand the desperation
but we also
believe that if we did that
we end up with something that could end
in a full-fledged war in europe
involving many more countries
and
causing much more human suffering
at a news conference with the president
of the european commission the u.s
secretary of state warned that the
conflict in ukraine may well be a
protracted one
unfortunately tragically horrifically
uh
this may not be over soon
and so these efforts that we're making
together we have to sustain them we have
to build upon them here at nato
headquarters there is a section from the
berlin wall the history of the alliance
can be divided into the period of the
cold war and then the period after this
wall fell the secretary general believes
the alliance has now passed a new
milestone what he's calling a new normal
and for the first time foreign ministers
have been discussing a permanent
long-term presence of many more troops
in the nato countries closest to russia
james bay's al jazeera at nato
headquarters in brussels